the great scholar al-hasan al-basri
was passing by the marketplace in basra iraq and he hears people calling others to come
purchase their products and in particular he hears one man with buckets of ice and this
man says o people have mercy on the one whose capital is melting away the man
is trying to urgently quickly sell his ice before it melts away this is a famous
story al-hasan abbasid allah starts to think of time
imagine you and i we had a sense of urgency to use our time wisely before
it melted away like this man was using his time wisely to sell his ice before
it melted away
do you have a sense of urgency with your time or are you reckless with it
do you allow it to disappear we consist of time
hours and days and minutes and seconds and for some people years and decades once an
hour passes it doesn't return it doesn't return until the day of judgement to testify for
or against you allah
reminds us in the quran in surah
in allah mean
allah has purchased from the believers
their lives and their wealth in exchange for paradise you're using your time in this world
whether it's 20 years or it's 120
years for the sake of allah
and your wealth and as you use your time for the sake of allah there's a
return on your investment the return on that investment is allah will grant you jannah for
how long how much time do you get in jannah for worshiping allah subhanahu wa it's
eternal and so you can see obviously that the most reasonable thing for any one of
us to do is to use this time limited time that you have
as wisely as possible for an investment that is eternal in nature when you think of
how society
protects things and the way that there are security measures for things that people value for
example with banks and security at banks with pieces of art and jewelry around the world
the types of security that you hear about or you see and so on and so
forth people protect things that they value
and oftentimes for example when you value your life you're going to take measures to protect
your life when you value your home you might put an alarm system for example to
protect your home because you value that thing you protect it the question is do we
protect our time there are many things around us that we protect in society many material
things but do we protect our time are we very cautious or do you allow anyone
and anything that wants your time to take your attention away to kill your time to
waste it the most precious blessing that we have it was reported once that a righteous
scholar on his way to the mosque to the masjid to pray was stopped by a
man who was known to waste a lot of time and the man said something along
the lines of can we go and kill time or let's go and kill time this
might be translated as let's go kill time let's go chill for a few hours in
other words let's go just waste time
and the scholar responded back to him and said can you hold the sun for me
meaning can you stop time so that i can kill time when you say i'm killing
time and you think i want to kill time in other words you are saying i'm
killing a part of myself because you consist of time do you protect your time do
you value your time for the sake of allah subhanahu wa
wisdom necessitates that the believer is protecting the most precious thing that they have and if
you were to be asked what is the purpose of life why do you exist hopefully
your response is based on reality allah
who created us told us why we exist allah
the one who created death and life in order to test you to see who's best
in their conduct it's all about your good deeds it's all about the worship of allah
the pleasure of allah the pursuit of paradise may allah
grant us that so if you know what the purpose of life is the question is
how do you attain it how do you facilitate it other than through your time so
you must to protect the purpose of life you must be protecting your time and yet
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
two blessings
good health and free time and think about the example of the one maybe yourself family
member or others when they fell ill or they went through a severe illness may allah
protect us and grant us shifa and our loved ones around the world but when that
person fell through or experienced a type of illness they wished for their energy to come
back so they could worship once again they wish they could do things like they had
not done before the time that they had wasted when they had good health they wasted
that opportunity and that energy and now they are regretting it and it's not coming back
to them as well as free time use your time wisely before you have more responsibilities
before things get more difficult generally speaking for the believer there isn't time to waste there
isn't time to kill there's no such thing as i'm bored i have nothing to do
there's always something to do with the limited time that you have but you must first
value it in order for you to protect it as a beautiful quote from a scholar
and i'm taking only two parts of this quote but he said
essentially know that your mind cannot contain everything so dedicated to the most important of matters
your mind consumes many things you are exposed to many things every day now if you're
someone for example who uses
any digital devices or accesses the internet on a daily basis you're exposed to many things
every single day you're exposed to media you're exposed to things you watch the videos movies
entertainment tv shows the books that you're reading whatever it may be you're exposed to social
media you're exposed to the news in general you're exposed to your work your career your
studies choose wisely the most important of matters because your mind cannot consume everything and you
have to choose the things that are prioritized the things that are important the things that
are beneficial if you're wasting a lot of time
for example on fiction on things that are fake the things that are uh useless the
things that don't have value and may even have doubtful or prohibited matters within them ask
yourself the following question does it make sense for a person to spend an hour two
hours three hours every single day every day of the year watching uh characters and watching
people pursue their false or fake dreams through these movies and tv shows while you're killing
your time not pursuing your dream for the sake of allah
not pursuing your purpose in life know that your mind has limitations you cannot take in
everything you cannot do everything so dedicated to the most important of matters and know that
your day and your night are limited and you have some essential needs so make sure
that you are managing the times of rest and the times of activity for the sake
of allah